bonsoir jeannette bougrab alors vous
êtes universitaire on vous connais vous
avez été secrétaire d'état dans le
gouvernement ump de françois fillon
présidente de la halde la haute autorité
de lutte contre les discriminations
c'était en 2010 ce qu'on sait pas
forcément sur vous c'est que vous êtes
originaire de notre région vous êtes
berrichonne je suis berrichonne je suis
né à châteauroux j'ai fait toutes mes
études secondaires au lycée jean
giraudoux de châteauroux j'ai fait une
partie de mes études de droit à
l'université d'orléans et ensuite j'ai
fait un d eux a un doctorat à la
sorbonne donc c'est pour ça que j'étais
avec une particulière émotions de vous
revenir sur mes terres en tout cas sur
cette magnifique campus de au relais sur
votre lieu d'étude la fac d'orléans vous
étudiez le le droit on a vu en tout à
l'heure les images de la conférence que
vous teniez sur la laïcité c'est la
laïcité c'est quelque chose qui me tient
à coeur
la laïcité c'est l'émancipation pour les
femmes la laïcité c'est ce qui permet en
tout cas le vivre ensemble et
aujourd'hui je suis extrêmement le mâle
heureuse de voir que cette laïcité est
apte active et c'est mon combat je le
mène depuis des années et je le mène au
nom d'une femme celui de combat de ma
mère alors justement dans ce livre que
vous publiez maudite chez albin michel
vous retracer votre propre parcours le
parcours d'une fille de party dans le
berry c'est important pour vous de vous
livrer sur ce parcours c'est surtout en
fait un livre hommage à ma mère c'était
cette héroïne invisible celle qui a été
ma boussole celle qui a connu l'enfer et
que pourtant va réussir à rompre en tout
cas le cycle de la violence à l'endroit
des femmes et qui a permis à ses filles
ma soeur salima et moi-même de d'accéder
à l'université de pouvoir faire des
études de pouvoir être indépendante
émancipé celle ce que à quoi elle n'a
jamais eu droit elle qui est née en
algérie
c'est aussi dans le bon camp celui de
l'émancipation des femmes l'accession
des falaises dans le monde arabe dans le
monde arabo musulman parce que je suis
la fille la petite fille de femmes qui
ont été mariés à 13 ans de forces celles
qui ont été violées d'un violeur
organisé par par leurs propres parents
il a je suis ému parce que je me vois
côté de mon père
lors de l'inauguration d'une des salles
de musculation rac à châteauroux voilà
vous y retournez souvent à châteauroux
puis j'y suis beaucoup je suis beaucoup
parce que ma mère est partie la semaine
dernière
et que j'ai accompagné ma mère jusqu'au
bout mes parents mon père mais par envie
faille ma mère vivait à déols et que mon
frère et militaire sur la base voilà
donc j'ai jamais couper les racines
c'est là où on a fait souche après la
guerre d'algérie c'est là aux mamans et
enterrés ou j'ai enterré la semaine
dernière et c'est là où moi même je
serai enterré voilà bientôt vous partez
pour la finlande je crois je pars en
finlande helsinki où je serai conseiller
culturel où j'aurai l'occasion en tout
cas de mener avoir des accords
universitaire entre helsinki et orléans
mais j'aurais déjà recevoir une
étudiante d'orléans qui vient on fait
dans le cadre d'erasmus en finlande
très bien merci beaucoup jeannette
bougrab d'avoir accepté notre invitation
je rappelle que votre livre ce livre
intitulé maudite et publié chez albin
michel merci merci beaucoup